thank you
oh welcome everybody
um to the council meeting tonight we
have a major light item later I don't
know two of them actually one to be held
in the open session which is the
um notes of the finance and projects
committee held on the 18th of April and
the second one is a supplemented paper
regarding the relocation of the South
and Museum collection update which flows
on from the last meeting here which will
be in public excluded
so I just want to Signal those to you
both come today
um so do I have any late apologies do
you want a motion that we've receive
yeah yes sir
Leslie and Darren yes
thank you any apologies I have Nigel
Scott at the stage
somebody like to move that those
apologies are accepted Maria thank you
thank you
okay working our way through the agenda
then um I'll do the the first minutes
first which is the uh the one that we've
just received which is a minute to the
finance and project committee dated uh
the 18th of April
to have I have somebody
okay any questions
Awesome Moving thank you
thank you grant any questions in
relation to those minutes
all those in favor carried
moving on to the minutes of the uh
council meeting held on the 28th of
March move
thank you Darren Trish thank you any
questions
all those in favor
the minutes of the infrastructure
committee meeting held on the 4th of
April
y thank you and also
um move the recommendation to council
that we adopt the invercargill city
council transport procurement strategy
yeah thank you a signal for that yeah
yeah thank you Alex uh any questions or
queries around those
there being none other requests ring
sure
that wasn't requesting of council was it
oh no no
we're all good yeah okay
so we've got the minutes and the motion
it goes and the issue that goes with it
all those in favor
carried
the minutes of the bluff community board
meeting
on the 17th of April yeah
Grant thank you
Ellen thank you any discussion
Survivor
I'm carried Minister the community
wellbeing committee held on the
18th of April moved
yes thank you and I'll see you know
Leslie thank you and any questions
there being none all those in favor
aye
carried
now we come to the long-term plan
Regional and environment
and that comes with a suite of 13
recommendations
Rihanna
councilors so is this paper present
presents forward for your consideration
recommendations regarding the region and
environment elements in preparation for
the long-term plan
it covers the topics of climate change
New River Estuary
the regional public transport plan
amongst others I'll take the reports
Road and happy to answer any questions
uh questions cancels
Rihanna and you get away pretty free on
that
I've got a I've got a couple of
questions
um and the carbon Zero part of the
report on page three of your report
um
it it talks about
carbon zero total by or Target by 2050.
and I just
I guess when you listen to the uh
some of the news media around
um around this issue sort of Wonder a
little bit sometimes about some of the
other long-term targets that we've been
party to like smoke-free New Zealand by
2024 or whatever it is 25.
um and other plans of being no no Road
deaths on the roads at uh 20 40. I just
wonder
um
whether we have a coordinated approach
to these long-term issues very long-term
issues or whether there should be some
more Regional aspect to it what your
view on that might be
well this is an issue that's being
discussed by the regional working group
and yeah councilor Campbell may wish to
speak to it as a representative sure
Tom
so one question chair that we need to
think about is whether we talk when we
talk about carbon zero whether that be
for the region or whether or for the
Regional Council house
um set a self-attack it for or in her
case whether we're talking about us as a
council or invercargill as a city I mean
there's totally different things
so obviously
um if the target has been set for us as
a city
um which I think we should search as a
such a Target I don't think it should be
as far as 2050 because the you know 2050
we should be thinking in terms of you
know the whole country or even the whole
city
um so I think you need to think about
that distinction I I think when we
talked about this uh the um that climate
change meeting
um and it may be that either Rihanna and
Leslie both of whom were the inmate
comment but it wasn't absolutely clear
to me whether
um environment Southland were speaking
about that as a target for the whole of
Southland of whether we're talking about
it as a target for an environment
Southland there's totally different
things obviously yeah
um but my view is that we should set a
target for the city council which is
perhaps you know 2040 or something like
that I live in a clear 10 years for the
you know for the broader environment
yeah
and again
um
from a mineral perspective uh across the
zones that we went to recently this
issue keeps raising its head that the
government expects us as a council as a
territory authority to be doing stuff
towards climate change
but it seems as though there's not a lot
of regional
coordination of that it seems to be
lacking still
um and certainly
um it was a view of many mayors at that
forum and at previous forums that
climate change should be a environment
South on type issue that the regional 14
Regional councils would be far better to
coordinate that than have everybody do a
little bit but no coordination of the
overall time you get into
loosely
um
as Tom said I also attend those meetings
and I think it's
very clear for me since we have attended
that the Regional Council and
um here we are taking the lead on that
as a regional issue but specifically the
way the recommendation is written here
as Tom said recommendation sixes asking
for officers to prepare guidance to
support determining and appropriate time
frame for the Target and as Tom
indicated that may indeed mean that we
decide that air Target will be
um quite a few years before the Target
that has been set Nationwide or may be
set for the entire region and I think
that's a conversation as well worth us
having them well worth asking officers
for the advice on there are things we
can obviously do as a council some of
them we have already started
um which
could
change their time frame considerably for
the better yeah
and question two for you Rhianna is on
page four of your report that talks
about Coastal plan and access to a Reedy
beach now this came up in the last term
where environment Southampton were
seeking some guidance I guess from us
about
our views on uh having limited access to
Reiki Beach or certain parts but not
able to be accessed and one of the
options was Total Access so I guess this
issue is coming up again
but one of the issues in the on your
third bullet point is that it talks
about indigenous biodiversity including
Terror
and I understood at the time of that
debate it wasn't my
that was my understanding that there was
some discussion around where the Torah
was actually
um an indigenous species to to Really
Beach or whether it was an introduced
species and I think the advice we got
from
uh who was he used to be a council or
Lloyd Isla and some of the historians
said it was actually introduced so I get
that wrong no he did
that's all right
[Music]
so we have a suite of um
13 recommendations
happy to put them oh sorry Alex
thank you Mika I was just going to um I
guess I've got a question that I'm not
sure that I've seen recognized
throughout the report or any any other
previous climate change reports that
we've had
um recently at my young elected members
committee meeting we were talking about
climate change and mitigation adaptation
and one of the things that both Nelson
city council and kapiti city council um
are doing is offseating a whole lot of
the parks land and returning it to
Native Plantation and um you know right
here in planting and that some things
all over the show and I wondered if that
was something you know like being one of
the largest Parks areas
um per person per populist invercargill
city is that something that we would be
considering under that I know that my
committed members talked about how it be
it's a much larger upfront cost
um but that obviously offsets over time
is the reduction in Mowing and planting
and stuff yeah I can probably talk to
that
um so a couple of issues um I know
Nelson really well so I guess
um some of the land they will have will
not be on flat land it will be on
sloping land and so they're looking to
to avoid the storm water type runoff
that they get from properties that was a
lesson that was learned from Auckland
and to a lesser extent in Hawke's Bay
that if you intensify your footprint as
far as housing concern you take away the
land's ability to absorb water and so
everything just runs off
um so that's that's an issue for all
councils to resolve I guess in our case
most of our land would actually be flat
land
and probably not in in prone areas areas
that we we might have intensity of
Housing and might want to avoid some
runoff not an expert on that but we do
have some earmarking of some of that
land for a building project that we've
got as well that try and build other
houses in the city Elderly Care houses
so it's a bit of a trade-off there I
guess
but it's certainly something we need to
look at and I know under the new spatial
planning
um
exit coming into in the power that we
will have to look at that sort of issue
about about where we have green spaces
that can sponge up uh excess water
running
yeah uh Evelyn oh sorry
um two different things climate change
is being run by environment South and
with ewe the carbon zero issue is a
different
we may have some issues in that space
and want to have conversations in that
space But just to not get the two issues
confused
um so just supporting what um the deputy
mayor said that we should be looking at
a staged incremental plan towards 2050
and starting it as soon as possible
across our businesses so if I look at
what I get from Torino or nataku it
actually talks about these these issues
um with every business decision or every
decision we make what are the
implications in terms of carbon and to
follow up with what councilor crackhead
said the issue of
replanting areas that have previously
been planted in Pine with indigenous as
I think the point that she was making we
have got land say it at Sandy Point and
um other places where this could happen
but also we need to actually look at
what we're doing within the inner city
where we're still planting introduced
trees on the basis that that's what's
been there for the last 100 years we
know more now than we did then could we
please reconsider some of that so that
what is seen in the city I'm not
suggesting for a moment that we plant
lots of tea coca but I would love it if
we planted lots of Kofi and Kaka beak in
southern rata
um you know so it's changing the way we
think about things and not just keeping
doing what we did before because that's
what we've always done in terms of
tree planting thank you
thank you Leslie do you want to
I was
recommendation yep
are you signaling that Darren thank you
um any discussion around that all those
in favor
aye Gary thank you
and you're up again Rihanna
um so this paper deals with the response
to the 2324 draft statement of intent
from invercargill City Holdings Limited
attached is the proposed letter of
response as well as some changes to the
proposed policy for the adoption of
directors with some further options for
you to consider which could be made to
that document it's in response to the
conversation between the board of the
holding company and Council and covers
the priorities that were discussed
for your consideration
I've been for christening here rangi
um like
this is a bit of a da Vinci Code to me
it um I've got
can I ask the question is holco's
dividend accounts or is it solely made
up of what dividend comes from eil is
that correct
from the power company part of the
business yes from me or from eil which
is a lions company yeah yes yeah okay so
what what part of that dividend does
roaring 40s contribute
I can't answer that specific question no
that's okay because I can work with that
so what what it says basically is that
we're getting four million dividend from
this year from holco which is 4 million
from eil neck Nets occurred after
discussions
between ichl and eil they've come to
four million yet
um for the next three financials a year
a Year's 2024 25 and 26 you'll see in
the statement of intent
they're predicting 5.2 million dollar
dividends now these are up
1.2 million dollars and that's factoring
in the comment that
eil is going to be selling roaring 40s
energy
so
I don't know my my maths would say that
roaring 40s energy is actually a
liability and we're going to make more
money without it I just don't understand
the figures so I can speak to the first
part of your question counselor so you
may recall that the holding company
board confirmed that they were debt fund
the
um dividend for Surety for Council so
that's the difference the one this year
yes so um and that's what this relates
to 23 24.
um going forward that's absolutely a
matter for consideration the second part
of your question would need to be
directed to Andrew Cameron
who I see is there
are you able to answer Andrew will
always save it for another day
at this stage we're on the 40s is not
being sold what council consolator on
the holding company agreed to do was to
transfer the shares in Roaring 40s from
uh ail to the holding company directly
and there's some other changes that are
going on with respect to the dividend
but we can talk about those
well now if you really want to oh no
it's just the big one is how much
how much do does roaring 40s contribute
yeah I'm just trying to get it
value or it's you know important
um I suppose uh those matters uh
touching on Commercial matters which
would probably be better off go with
separately we will become clearer once
it's held correctly by the Holden
company
um you'll be able to see those those
returns more clearly at that stage but
at this stage it's held within a
different group and a different
structure but I take it they all
currently they will merge together to
form whatever dividend
um but there is more than one entity
held by uh El Christie invercargill that
gets Consolidated before it makes its
way through to the holding company
right oh interesting invercargill if you
look at the group structure own has a
number of Investments yeah yeah but when
it pays its dividend it's it's Dragged
In all its Investments and then passes
it on to us yes that's correct okay
right but we can't really talk about
what the split is no
no that's okay
um
right no that's all thanks yeah great
well I think Tom was first
did you have time did you no no I got
around on my list okay
um just with respect to the director
appointments um
I read a sort of a question around
governance training being provided by
ichl
um is that you're asking us if we think
that should happen or have you made a
decision around that
it's an issue for Council to consider
and there's two schools of thoughts in
this uh I have a view with respect to
the role of
um form of better description public
sector entities in there enhancing the
skills based across the community more
generally the countervailing view is
that you pay directors appropriately and
they should look after their own
Education and Training um so it just
depends on which side of the French you
sit on I think if we go down the path of
having trainee directors then it's
probably something that's more of an
issue if we have trainees uh we expect
that part of that training year or
whatever we put in place do we expect
that we would do some continued
professional development for them or not
that's really as much as anything where
it's coming from okay thank you so
secondary would be in my view
um I agree if you're a director on a
company like that you should train
yourself you should be of sufficient
skill to be able to do the job when
you're appointed and if there's any
further development then that's up to
you to do that that's personal
development and growth which you benefit
directly from
secondly I do I'm supportive of a
associate director
position on with a net entity I think as
long as it's Tech to being a local
person
because I think that helps increase and
enhance our capability and Community
around the ability to govern those sort
of entities and organizations and a
third point just in terms of the 40 of
the board to be from within Southland
um I my view on that should be sixty
percent not 40. I think it should be
significantly higher than more than 50
of the board
um and if we have a
associate director role within those
entities
um then we're naturally being able to
fill those positions as they come up
because that we're training your own
thought thing
so that's only my view but I think there
should be trying to be interested in
other council's view on it cool uh Tom
so I guess I'm traversing pretty much
the same subject
um
Rihanna when we discussed this before I
I actually thought we were talking about
50 silverish so I'm interested in how 50
became 40 is the first question
secondly
um we were talking about all of the
boards not only ichl but also the
subsidiary boards too when we talked
about having local directors but I
noticed in this paper it's limited to
ichl which would have no impact because
already are half the directors are are
local
so the concern I think that we were
expressing in in the earlier meeting was
the fact that we have moved from you
know three or four years ago to a
situation where all of the directors on
eil and per Network local
tier position three or four years later
when none of them are local
so that that was considered more
semi-considered by me but I think by the
meaning as a whole has been a concern so
that that was why we proposed that it
should be 50 or whether it's 40 or 50 or
60 I'm I'm assume I don't greatly care
but but let's say 50 but that should
apply to the subsidiary companies as
well as to the holding company and
that's not reflected in here
so through your chair
um the reason for the
um inclusion of 40 was on further
discussion and advice from the holding
company themselves around managing risk
about having appropriate
um
skill set on the board so it's certainly
something for you to consider now and if
you wanted to make that change we could
and secondly I can't see any reason why
we can't um change the policy to more
reflect the discussion because I think
that is an inaccuracy that it only
related to the holding company and not
to the it was not the intention in the
drafting of the policy so that can be
fixed
thank you
yeah
no no no not you
um
I um also think that the um just didn't
know that he asked me um also feel that
we should include a counselor as a
member of the uh as a director on the
appointments committee because
um they're our companies I I think there
should be at least one counselor on
there and I um
do not require
I
do not require membership of The
Institute of directors as a criteria for
membership I'd rather that we didn't
require that because I think that limit
share
your people okay I think you know yeah
most people I know aren't
but yeah they might be civil directors
if I just want to use the chairs for if
I can just fly against the white that
was in there goes to the training issue
so obviously The Institute of directors
requires people to undertake training
the the risk the council uh faces is
that if you're not a member of The
Institute of directors and we don't
provide
or require or provide the training
ourselves you've got a risk they don't
do any ongoing training that that's what
that is that is
it possible you save all year I've got
to point you but you need to do this uh
we could do it becomes a monitoring
issue so that that's all that's in there
for
rare
um thank you Mr chair um
I'm off the appetite that anyone that we
approved for directorships over our
companies
should have the school set that does
come from The Institute of directors
we seem to be at risk if we're getting
Tom Tom Dick and Harry on there with
very little experience in how to run
companies such as what we have
I'm also in favor of having no less than
50 of the directors being um locally
based I know that we did discuss that in
depth I think that was what we had said
would be the lowest
um percentage of acceptance
um
I'm not sure how I would feel
if we have a council member a point the
directors it's like choosing your mates
I think there's a transparency issue
that could arise
um but yeah that's my feedback to that
area
a ringy
um look speaking on the uh counselor as
a member of the committee I would
actually remove Council our input and
put Mia there um takes away the the
hassle of actually choosing the elected
member and puts the mayor in there and I
don't see any conflict I or I just think
it brings it slightly back
the balance towards this Council
considering how many are on that
appointments committee is there
three plus Council
and yeah and I suppose again if I could
just address that the thinking behind
that through use the chair it was really
[Music]
um
identifying the risk that once we go
down the path of nominating a minimum
number of local candidates
it would
preempt the issue where the
recommendations come up to council that
does not satisfy that criteria that at
least you would have the comfort that a
councilor the mayor whoever it happens
to be who sat on that panel understands
why a local candidate wasn't the
preferred candidate it's just a preempt
that discussion was really the risk that
I see that being able to manage so when
I first when I first got on Council in
2010 the chief executive was on the
appointments committee now I don't think
a staff member can be on a council
committee is that no is that true I
don't it can be no he can't be so I
think I got that changed but
um
yeah so I would support that for the
very reason that Andrew said and as far
as the instituted directors as a
criteria goes now is it true
that you can just join you can pay a
certain sub and join the members and be
a member it's a compulsory amount of
training you have to go through yeah
yeah
but I'm saying that does not give you at
the coal face training you've got the a
course or something like that but it's
really your business
Acumen built up over years that is the
key thing
and and uh you know I I think that
should be more weighted uh in your CV
that shows that you've obviously run a
company that's uh had a turnover of X
you know amount there's I see that as
more important so that there's my
comments on those tuitions yeah Alex
thank you Mia Clarke um first of all
look really like to toe talk or um the
deputy mayor and Ria's conversation so
councilor bonds conversation
um I my reflection of the conversation
was that we were absolutely adamant that
we wanted to be at least 50 local and um
for it to kick through all of our
subsidiaries rather than just sit at the
top that higher level
um I actually have a contrary opinion to
the people before me and I would really
appreciate and I would say that yes we
need our directors to be members of The
Institute of directors I think for
directors or anybody that we have
appointed to our committees we want to
see a commitment to lifelong learning
and that is you know if we're not
providing those formal training options
for them and asijo then we know that
they're completing at least this minimal
amount of CPD training and have that
commitment to keeping up with the
knowledge that's relevant in the
industry at the time it's not just a you
get like you know your magazines you get
your newsletters you get all sorts of
stuff as well was the commitment and
access at a subsidized rate to actually
undertake some more formal governance
training
so I would much rather see them have
have the Institute of director's
membership I also think that that
provides a room or a bit more room for
those people that might be slightly more
Junior in their careers we're not all
well I would appreciate that there'd be
a cross-section of skill sets and
demographics across our company boards
and that membership you know I think
would be really beneficial to those that
are you know potentially my age or just
a bit older thank you
Tom
so on the matter of the Institute
director's membership anybody around
this table and actually quite a few who
are outside this table could join just
by a phone call and a credit card not
difficult to join it
um it costs 570 dollars to join and
that's an annual subscription so it's
it's not cheap
um you can join in two ways either as an
associate member where you don't require
actually do the training that
um there's an order you can join as a
film member
where again you're not required to do
the training but you're encouraged to do
the training but the training is
expensive right so you're some of these
courses can be a thousand dollars two
thousand dollars
so bear in mind that we are actually
here not talking about directors of the
um subsidiaries we're talking about
membership of the appointments committee
yeah
I don't personally see that a counselor
who's a member or a mayor who's a member
of the appointments committee that needs
to be a member of The Institute of
directors I don't see any reason for
that yeah it's it's a different debate
about whether the directors that we
appoint should be members of The
Institute of directors but we're just
just bear in mind that central
government appoints directors to 64.
businesses
so they appoint hundreds of directors
they do not require membership with ncj
directors to be appointed as a director
because they are looking for people from
various backgrounds to become directors
and we should too so I either I'm not as
weird I mean Institute of directors is
not greatly different from joining you
know the Automobile Association you just
phone up your credit card and you
remember when you come off the call so I
I don't I think you can put too much on
it certainly for a member of the
committee the appointments committee I
don't think it's necessary
as for who could you considered whether
directors are appointed
should be already members of IUD or not
they don't require it at the moment sure
so just just reflect on that you raise
two answering points um one is whether
we need an institution director on the
selection panel or whether we
subsequently need their criteria to be
applied across the appointments as well
I'm personally opposed to both and
partnership close your ears for a minute
now but I've had the same experience
back in registered social worker days as
well and the people that were making the
decisions which is the appointment panel
type level
majority of them want to read some
social workers so you could never get
much traction for anybody of Merit that
wasn't a recent social worker and so
that's it becomes the primary focus it's
a little bit like well we'll we'll have
10 applicants and eight of them are
Institute members so we'll look at those
eight first yeah and that I think Gates
keeps out some good some good candidates
so
Brianna wants to call me
so just for clarification because I can
see that that wording is not clear it is
intended 0.4 B to relate to the
membership of the boards not the
appointment committee but I can see why
it's read the way that it has been in
that last comment so just a matter of
clarification and also
um just to point out that the current
policy does not include A and B they are
there for your discussion to see whether
you want to do it or not sure so I'm
working through the list Leslie
thank you
as applying to the appointees not to the
committee meeting was
um and I I do point out on that one that
actually if you look at the policy
um it does say that all Council
appointed directors to council control
trading organizations must comply with
the Institute of directors code of
conduct
so it seems to me that actually asking
them to apply to
comply with the code of conduct and it
would imply that it is absolutical that
we expect them to actually be members as
well
um create um
going back to the other points I was
going to make because that one was was
the subsidiary point I did want to make
the coin over 50 that was my definite
understanding after our last discussion
that we had clearly said 50 and across
the board so we hadn't just made it to
apply the beholding company sure we had
indicated that it should be in across
the board
um meta
um
and the other method sorry I'll just go
back to
um The Counselor as a member of the
director appointments committee
I just think this council is at the
point where there is a is a common sense
appointment
um
alone the fact that we have a counselor
or indeed the Mia would make it even
simpler as a member of that committee
means that we don't have
um
appointment recommendations coming back
to us that we reject for reasons that
having a mayor or a counselor on the
committee would have helped one
um we've we've made it clear what we
would like to see in future appointments
it would just be useful to actually have
that um standby of me or a counselor
being there to um ensure that the
criteria we've asked for is put in place
so I I do think that's sensible and I I
do think um
if we're asking them to comply with the
code of The Institute then
I just think it's Common Sense weird
it's the end of their members of it so
just let me comment to that I guess
um so if that was the case when we
advertised we'd have to make it
blatantly clear
that you had to be a member of The
Institute to be making an application so
sure
yeah until until we get to Stage which
Tom says that somebody that's interested
can become a member very very easily and
so as we get through this others that
want to speak we might need to look at B
again and instead of saying require or
not require it could say recommend and
so recommend does leave the door open
for some discretion that you're just not
automatically taking Institute members
and and student Members Only
and and and reiken oh sorry Alan can um
do the policy appropriately well if I
can if I can just comment this sure and
leave it for size if we're saying as
part of our advertising that we expect
any appointee that we would look at to
comply with the roles of that Institute
yeah I just don't see it's any different
from saying we actually require but
again what I'm suggesting is that the
this outcome and be instead of saying
require not required could say recommend
and then when you get to the
um the code condo you could say it
speaks to abide by the code of conduct
so you can still adopt it but if you're
adopting somebody else's code of conduct
you've really got to have their members
and their Members Only I mean if I think
about the social work situation they've
got a code of conduct as well and it
applies only to members of the of their
Collective or their Institute it doesn't
apply to non-members so so the only
thing I would add to that is that the um
the the conduct of company directors is
prescribed in law
it's you know the IOD don't own that
code of conduct it's actually you know
legal
um so they are required whether they
want you know required in law to comply
with that could have conduct but uh but
I think the the
I think the most my view the more she
would you could see as the directors are
required to commit to joining the IOD
after appointment if they're not already
I don't think you should make a
requirement of applying being in mind
it's going to cost somebody 600 just to
apply so it'd be completely
inappropriate to be asking people
anybody who's going to be interviewed
for a job to pay 600 to join you know
Darren
I'm quite comfortable with there being
an elected representative and agree with
the sentiment that it should be the
mayor on the director appointments
committee I'm reasonably confident there
would be somebody with IOD membership
that was on it as well and that
satisfies my need I think Tom's
suggestion just then that if somebody is
not already a member of The Institute of
directors and picking up on Alex's point
it's way cheaper if you're younger I can
assure you it was a bug beer for those
of us who are over in age
um that they commit to joining
afterwards yes you want someone who's
got good business Acumen but there is
quite a distinction between running your
own business and moving from management
and operations to uh to to that
governance role and I think that's where
the IOD is really worthwhile as a member
okay
Ellen
um yeah I just remember somebody saying
that um when you get appointed as a
Committee Member uh on the committee to
a point directors or you are actually
Enrique yourself
you're appointed because of what you
already know or what you do these are
not roles that you go in to learn
to do these roles I mean if you want a
director for a company you want the best
person don't you who's actually able to
do the job you don't have to go there
and learn to do the job do you that's
not what it is all about because
director is what it says it means it
gets to give direction
that's correct does not
the direction of the company is a
governance role ideally the answer is
yes yeah
so
yeah I
suppose we flagged that we would put in
place a trainee program sort of in
addition to the existing directors uh
where appropriate to try and build up
the local
experience base but but you would expect
to call directors making the decisions
to be uh able to make those decisions
from day one or experience
uh Grant yeah the the 60 thing is
important because a lot of these boards
are five or seven members so you can't
have 50 or half of two five people so
you've either got to go 40 or 60.
being on a five-person board you've got
three of the five uh being sixty percent
are from Southland we're on a seven
person board
you can't have fifty percent of five
people being from Southland well you
might be able to but I can't my world
Trish
it's like to endorse um councilor
soper's comments with regard to the
person counselor on the appointments
committee I think the connection that
the council has was that appointments
committee is really important and as we
as Leslie said it was identified and you
know when we didn't approve her to read
it so I think it's quite important sure
so
um we've got two recommendations in
front of us
um and if somebody wants to move I'll
make some amendments
um I think the word counselor shouldn't
be there it should be elected member so
if you think about today's environment
um that's why it's saying to me should
be there but I think Tom's got more
skills in this area than I've got
but that can change as as
terms change as well that's not to say
that Tom would particularly be there I
could be there but I think if you leave
elected member again you pick the people
with the right skills to sit on that
selection selection panel
and the other option is to not require
or not require in Part B
but just recommend and that leaves some
discretion open
so that the people that are making the
selections can come back to us if there
were people they wanted to include on a
board that didn't have the Institute of
directors uh tick alongside their name
Alex
thank you me Clark I wondered if perhaps
and I
of Jay were you going with this um point
B here but I I would wonder if we could
test the table on um uh Deputy me
Campbell's
um suggestion and that we you know
recommend membership of Institute of
directors as a criteria for membership
but then also subsequently to their
appointment
request that they do
if they if they haven't already
well I guess one of the things that
having to require and not require is
that if one side of one boat gets can
gets beaten the other one will
automatically apply so what I'm
suggesting is there may be better
options and require or not require
um because I think there are people
around the table that wouldn't require
so
I think that's sort of future I mean
we're going to be careful that we don't
you know we're kind of eating whole
cause lunch here when we start to get
down to that level to me as a a council
that's it should be acceptable we
recommend uh I mean I think it is
actually then for Hulk or to you know
make that determination you know then oh
he's gone what then happens subsequently
yeah
um whether they then require so if you
if you look at both eil and pernet at
the moment everybody's a member of
Institute of directors
um all of them do do the ongoing
training which other professional
institutes do now the days when you
became a chartered engineer and 50 years
later you were still a child with
engineer gone same as directors you've
got to do ongoing Life Training
um but both eil and pefila so it's not a
free thing for us I mean it does
actually cannot expect
um direct us to be paying thousands of
dollars to go to courses I don't think
so I I think personally I think you can
leave it at recommend and allow Hoku
then to interpret that how they will I
think whole call Will interpret it as
meaning should belong subsequently sure
and I would expect that our Council
would would say in the policy look if
you go to a point something it's not
directly you need to come back to us so
we have some understanding of why you're
going out what is the normal criteria
and the same for the 60 split that Grant
was talking about if for some reason we
couldn't satisfy 60 being locals for
whatever reason
um they they don't take it in theory
candidate just to fill the sixty percent
that's right they come back and say look
actually you know if we look for the
quality people we've got we're going to
end up with 40 60 the other way also be
at least it comes back to us and we
don't end up with what we've got at the
moment which is all the directors being
on a power company being external
so so just a point of clarification then
sorry
by giving the nod to the adoption of
this policy appointment we're either
accepting 40 yep
is it stated in the paper because we
we want to change the 50 even though you
can't have 50.
on boards if there's five or seven
people
if you see at least 50 if there's the
odd number you described in the end up
if it's at least 50 percent instead of
seven at least fifty percent is four so
you end up with the same income right
okay as long as that's clarified
have you got all those
I do but I wonder if given how important
this point is to the council you might
like to add C
I just took 50 of membership at least 50
for sure yeah yeah
no less than 50 percent
should you again share I think we have
to be very careful that we don't allow
card routes too easily because I can
think another board that we that was
said actually in the trusted
looking it done where we ended up with
all external appointments so you must
must be careful about what the one thing
that comes after it does not allow some
yeah you know yeah yeah Leslie
thank you I just thought while while
we're adjusting the word and could we
just to be
change the word membership so it says as
a criteria for appointment as a director
so that it's absolutely clear so it's
able to clarify my understanding of it I
just think it would be if we're tidying
at word and let's tidy that one up as
well so it is
clear that that applies to
appointment as a director
so that would have to apply and see as
well then
if you can scroll up soccer CC well it's
already there so you don't need to
repeat it yeah but the membership no
it's the confusion with the membership
is that we're talking about the
membership of the selection panel or the
membership of boards yeah and we're
talking about boards
yeah
you still have do not require that
recommend as well
to you you've got you've got to um we
recommend that you have Institute of
directors
appointees if for some reason you think
that's what I'd say they're winning
sorry what if I said I didn't want to
um what I'm saying is to hold Co
if they wanted to default from that
position they'd have to come back to us
so we would like to have I know let's
say time on on the board and Tom's not
an Institute of director memo but we
think basically you might listen to that
Michael is a subject to require there
no it's a recommendation not a
requirement no I think when you when you
put the word require it becomes it gets
right as one of the primary criteria for
being on the board as an Institute of
directors and I just think we we need to
have a softer approach to that to allow
people that might be locals who might
have a skill set that we want
um you saw the three people sitting at
the top of the table during a workshop
wonder what it would be like if one or
one of those applied for one of our
boards and was an Institute with the
school Factor be okay
could well be
depending on what work we want done
I'm not saying I disagree with you I may
agree but I just think what you've
written there still
actually says require
D no it just says we recommend and it
leaves a softer approach as as Andrew
said
and our policy could then State come
back to us if that's not the default
position
we're going to have a link to remember
on the on the board anyway so they can
signal it
bring me look um this is all good having
members of the instituted directors on
your boards but we don't really have any
safeguards that they understand the
Local Government Act or do we assume
that they understand the act because
obviously not only yet do you have to
comply with the companies act everything
you do has to comply
with the local government act 2002. now
um you know it could be like we've got
uh you know she'd relates to do with a
statement of intents and stuff like that
and complying with various bits we've
got all sorts of stuff
that that applied to council trading
companies now
um how do we know that someone who's got
all these ticked all these boxes has
gone to
work within the bounds of the Local
Government Act we don't
um well I guess you'd have that in the
job advertisement you had and you'd be
saying to them well we'd recommend that
you have an instituted director
membership we would also like you to
display some understanding of working in
the Local Government Act and the local
government environment okay so you're
bringing in people so that's really yep
I mean that's what I've done in other
jobs Associated that guarantees their
performance yep yep and it gives them a
preference of the being in there it's
comforting to know yeah
all right if we're happy with those
sweets would somebody like to move those
recommendations
oh sorry I I made a mistake just one
issue
right and then back on
page three of your report or 40 42 of
board box and when it talks about other
strategic priorities including strategic
Holdings one of the one of the um
discussions we've had in recent times is
whether the likes of Don Street should
be sitting in icpl which is our property
division
and it may very well be at some later
State consideration what will need to be
affected into whether rugby park is also
there as well so there's been some
movement in the past about
removing the ownership of rugby park
away from the charitable trust that
we've got and into Council whatever into
Council means and for my benefit I think
it would be way more transparent for the
operation of rugby Parker be sitting on
a property company where we got annual
reports and and the money streams were
quite clear than to be putting it into
Council where it hops into a property
division with a whole lot of other
property as well
um so I just wanted to signal that so
um
I'll just signing down
there's um
a slight conflict with that and and that
we would need to be
quite explicit with
what we allowed
or what instruction we gave hold Co if
that were to be the case because
essentially we've said to to hold code
go forth and make money sure produce a
dividend
but the running of the outdoor stadium
requires factoring in
a substantial amount of money that we
call public good
and that sits outside the the halt go
around so that would need a bit of a bit
of thought sure yeah for sure it's just
we're sort of in the early stages of
looking we're we're rugby park would sit
in the future and what sort of occupancy
agreements would have with them trying
to get that wider engagement
so we've got those four recommendations
on the board I'll put I'll put one and
three to start with so they're quite
easy
yeah
a mover and a second to there yeah Tom
thank you ring it all those a favor
carried onto four now which um
if everybody's happy with those a b and
c then if we could have a move or a
second
thank you
yeah thank you
a mover and signal
Grace thank you Tom all those in favor
thank you for that
very small debate on that
and Michael
hello
Michael and Michael
thank you Mr Mayor we're carrying on
with statements of intent this is the
one for the
um charitable trust the current owner of
the outdoor stadium as you were just
talking about
uh the key recommendation for this is
that Council direct the trustees of the
trust to make the statement of intent
slightly more
future looking and aspirational staff
felt reading the statement of intent it
was quite backwards looking looking into
the past about what has happened as
opposed to looking to the Future
that was why that recommendation is
there and with
out needing to go too much further on
with that I'm very happy to answer any
questions
yeah I've got a couple so uh having been
on that trust or currently on that trust
has some my colleagues are
um
it seems to me that um
the trust is needed for the purposes of
the charitable status so there are
events that we held from time to time
where we can't attract funding towards
them unless we've got a charitable class
status so that I understand
but unfortunately we've also got rugby
park tucked under there as well which I
think is ultra confusing
um and so I guess as part of this paper
coming forward I'd like to signal that
we've already signaled that with the
trust but it would be helpful to have a
a greater understanding to know the
history of what's happened with the
purchase of rugby park I certainly don't
know last thing's been around a while
she's one of the trustees I think the
discussion we had the other day is
people are not clear about
what the arrangement is at rugby park
now and how we got to that position
that's not that's not a matter of trying
to blame anybody but just understand
what it is and and where the future
rugby park might better sit as an
ownership model as opposed to sitting in
that trust where I think it's probably
not the right place so if you can help
with that that would be great I will
work with the venues team to bring a
history background paper through to
discuss that that would be helpful uh
any questions in relation to the paper
which just can it outline where the best
place to own that yes it would be yes
that that's what we've looked at we've
currently got it in the trust
invercargill City charitable trust yeah
um one other option that was being
considered when the previous chief
executive was here was to bring it back
into call Council business which I was
uncomfortable with because I think
um she keeps hidden in with a whole lot
of other costs as well and then the next
option that came up was the potential to
be in the property company yes which
suits in Holcombe mentioned at the Brian
there our chair there he sort of went a
bit brighter in the face and said oh
well I'll take it if I have to
um but I do do think the ownership issue
is quite critical and with that we'll go
some realignment of the occupancy
agreements we have so we've got a
primary contract with the Rugby Union
but we've also got licenses to occupy
with the referees and with the
supporters clubs and they are
problematic at the moment not
problematic from the Rogan probably
problematic from Harry yeah that we
don't we don't have the right
expectations in those those contracts
but equally with their previous
discussion in the workshop this morning
just around you know strategic view of
ownership would be helpful to have in
the paper yep and so and so that that
issue is an important issue so we don't
want rugby to have exclusivity drug
report we've discussed that with the
rugby fraternity they're happy with that
um but how you overlay other
uh other facilities that come
organizations that might want to come in
so a really simple example is that if
you've got a supporters Club that's been
built up by the members and has a bar
facility and everything else if Rugby
Union go and have their final rugby game
on on the park who runs the bar
well Peter probably does anyway but I
mean where does the profit go and all
those subtle issues of being roadblocks
in the past and so I want to try and
smooth those out make sure we've got the
right sort of agreements in place
yeah Peter yeah thank you Mr Mayor uh
correct me if I'm wrong but I believe
the charitable trust was set up
and if in the way that if the chair put
all Christ wanted to
hold a large event there would give them
ability
to apply from outside funding sure and
what's that event is that correct that's
correct so my understanding of the
parent request was wiped no no I just
need to clarify that we we're not
suggesting at all that the general trust
goes so my understanding from
um
advice I was given as a member of the
trust was that the charitable trust
has the ability to track funding that
requires it to be going to a charitable
trust so uh
Christmas in the Park was an example but
there were other Street events that
we've got to get we could get funding
for so we still need to have the trust
that's not the issue the issue is
whether rugby park should be under the
trust or elsewhere where there's better
benefit for everybody if it was owned by
somebody other than the trust but the
Trussell will still stay now what came
up with a slight Twist of that is if you
ran something at rugby park that could
attract charitable trust then you had
that covered as well for example
yep you need to know who makes the
profit from the alcohol you've mentioned
it before no no no I just I just sang
before you know I can't clarify it oh
sure
uh
South and run all the alcohol on the
ground yeah and that goes back into
rugby all the profits sure uh rugby
supporters Club all the profits made
from alcohol and Raffles here goes into
junior rugby mainly rather up the grades
as well sure and I believe the referees
all the money they make as goes into
recruiting referees and other things
and you're right look I I don't want to
get sidetracked into that issue but I
mean um that was one of the issues that
came up recently with one of the games
um
so um you know using rugby league as an
example they're semi-finals and Finals
over a couple of weekends at rugby park
you wouldn't expect them to have to go
chasing around for a bar manager and
start working out the profit margins
being split between the rugby supporters
club and the rugby league you just get
the rugby supporters as a primary tenant
to run it they provide the bar manager
they arrange to stuff the people like
when the Highlanders came here sure well
the rugby supporters Club hand over
their Club rooms because it could be
used for a media center
referees do something similar sure
yeah so like if the finalist coming or
doesn't matter if you know I bought the
Warriors here 20 years ago yeah it was
the people that bought the wire is here
they needed every cent they could get so
but they rented the venue and and they
were in charge of the venue so the other
three people we've talked about three
groups they just step aside
all right got that all right any further
discussion on this paper
they're being none but somebody like to
move
oh well that's Darren and Leslie
together thank you very much
sorry that was my mistake yeah Grant
thank you
all right all those in favor all right
Carrie
and Michael again yes we're now moving
from statements of intent to the local
government New Zealand annual conference
uh this is the paper just to uh
bring to everybody's attention and to
seek approval for the uh councilors
pottinger bond in dumity as well as the
chief executive to attend the uh annual
conference and
Christchurch in July
saying too much more to that yeah
oh I've got to move on a signal thank
you
um any comments Trish
oh you can't move in seconds okay
just as a wheat um
a couple of bits of information in
relation to this um
just to note that the uh
uh three counters and a chief Executives
that are going are not going to kumagai
so we made a conscious decision not to
double up on on the sister city trip and
the um conference one because normally
we'd have a larger group going to the
conference certainly with the Bingo
South Island and we will be asked for
our preferential votes for somebody
um to cast on the new prison and
vice president of lgnz so that's coming
up so uh the current
uh presence during Crosby is standing
down
so this stage I don't know who the the
full list are but I do know that Sam
Broughton from Selwyn
and Dan Gordon from my macaroni have
both got nominations there
so some suitable day we'll need to
excise our
discussion around who we think should be
best for President and Vice President
and give somebody a casting vote when it
gets to the uh
yes down to the thing
any further discussions on that oh yes
everyone
um so I have raised in the past the
issue of us being able to go to Maori
members on the day before the Hui I've
had no information come to me about that
um can I express my disappointment I'm
really happy to get make my own way and
all those sorts of things but I would
think that we have to register through
you or not you in person
but through the ICC so it will be really
helpful if this could come to pany and
myself
um
so that we can make that choice
that information will be provided it's
still being worked through what that
looks like but it will be coming don't
worry on that
thank you because I just think we missed
out last year and I think it's quite
disappointing that this Council has made
the initiative to have representation
here but we're not getting linked in to
our gnz if I hadn't gone last year I
wouldn't know that the organization
existed
but I will declare my own preference I
think uh attendance at the local
government conferences for elected
members and elected members only
I am open to a a group decision on that
and which we can do at a later stage
yeah thank you
okay
um
we've got
oh sorry we've got to uh
um one counselor to be the presiding
delegate and one to be a
Mr Mayor we still need to put this
resolution first we've got to move her
into second air yep just need everyone
to say aye on a yeah
please but you need some clarification
on who's going to be no we're not up to
that one yet all right that's fine all
those in favor of them oh sorry I'm
moving a singer
the corner again all those in favor say
aye carried
thank you Mr Mayor this next paper is
dealing specifically with the issue of
the lgnz annual conference
the first part of the recommendations is
simply noting the time frames for any
remits that this Council may wish to put
through uh there will of course then be
an opportunity for this Council to
discuss uh the remits that do go through
and Direction can then be given to the
presiding delegate or delegates and the
last recommendation there number four is
to as you've just alluded to earlier Mr
Mayor at a point the presiding delegate
to vote uh on behalf of council at the
LG NZ annual general meeting sure and
with that I don't think I can add
anything further and we'll answer
questions it's gonna be happy to move
the full recommendations with uh
councilor Dermody as the council
presiding delegate and Council of
pottinger is the alternative
not a lot of thought required on the day
apart from participating in the debate
because Council will have given
indication on how it wishes votes to go
prior to
Heaven that yeah any discussion around
that
being none I'll put all four motions in
or former four recommendations all those
in favor
caring
and Michael again yes oh and Jason
you have a Duo X this time it's a change
from just listening to me song and dance
totally
thank you Mr me at this paper outlines
the
options available to council to
acknowledge and commemorate the upcoming
coronation of King Charles III uh it is
in accordance with his Majesty's wishes
and as uh indicated through from the
Department of internal affairs on what
is happening uh one of the key things to
note is that whatever it is that we as
the city do will be recorded and then
used as part of a national footage that
will be broadcast
in Auckland and Wellington Wellington
sort of be Wellington
um and will form part of the New Zealand
recognition of the first coronation in
70 years that can be acknowledged it's
important to note that the two key
options that we have provided there are
sort of two extremes of what can be done
and you can go for anything in the
middle so the option b which is
essentially the minimum level of uh
required to have a ceremonial tree
planting and then the third option is
the more extravagant
uh option with more involvement uh and a
bit more choreography required from
staff but not for us to Dart and just
make that very clear
and then the first option of course is
ever is to do nothing but our advice
would be that that is out of step with
what the rest of New Zealand is doing
uh and I think unless Jason wants to add
anything we're happy to answer any
questions sure thank you for that um my
personal preferences for option two
um even though it seems to be a slightly
closed event the location that's been
done and makes it open anyway
um
certainly option A for me option one not
an option because while there are
ongoing debates between whether between
the royalists and those who would like
to see us in an independent republic
um you've got to open it up for those
that want to respect the coronation and
it's important to also know Mr Mayor
just on that that if option towards the
option that is proceeded with it would
be able to be advertised as something
that public could come along come along
to it yeah for sure
any discussions lately
[Music]
I just
wanted to say so that it has been said
by someone my my preference would
actually be for option three this is the
first time in 70 years we do have a
relationship with the crown
which is no matter what you may feel
about
Republic or otherwise the factors that
the relationship is there
um
the additional invitees to that wider
relationship uh important parts of the
of that wider event are important parts
of the
um
makeup of New Zealand and also have
their various relationships with the
crown it would also
um widen it in ways that I think are
useful in the way of community links
with the Charities some of whom have the
crown as their patrons in this case so
my personal preference was that we went
for option three as a reasonably
significant event
um at 70 years since there has been a
coronation and it is a significant
relationship
as a local government organization where
you have
a fairly different relationship with the
crown and it's an important relationship
until New Zealand does have any
constitutional change which may or may
not be up on here own lifetimes
Trish
I'm sorry I'm not opposing of you cancer
so far I think that with the inclusion
of the public and um option two
we can cat we can cater for all those
people who might have been asked
personally I think we've done so much to
try and keep costs down and even though
it's only once in 70 years I think
option two is the one that I would
prefer
the next one might be 70 years
so Tom first
solid fever option two maybe it was some
bills and whistles it looks a little bit
stuck at the moment it's not too
difficult to look at it and see how it
can be you know the public or obviously
welcome it coming I'm going to put
barriers up
um one of the reasons I see option two
is because it is a sixth of May yeah and
the weather might be absolutely terrible
so you know providing food and so forth
is and what a lot of public coming is is
you know present some challenges so I
think we could do option two but maybe
tat up a little bit it does look a
little bit static at the moment
get ready
um just looking at the section financial
implications now is that only referring
to the cost of the uh plant as opposed
to the cost of providing
um either option two or option three
yeah the financial implications would be
as showing what option three would look
like option two will be
less than that
okay so one something and one's more
than the other
but we don't
know when I said we've provided for what
the maximum uh cost is likely to be yes
it's six thousand including the tree it
includes the tree well okay our Parks
team have very good relationships with
providers of trees that's good
that's okay look I'd go for option two
because how do you cater for a crowd
that you got no idea for and the food
allergies and stuff like that and I
think I think the other thing is that
when you start embodying the heads of
police and fire service and everybody
else it puts a bit of an Oneness on them
that they feel as though they have to
come as opposed to people coming because
they want to actually be there
[Laughter]
yeah exactly
any further discussion
all right Mr Mayor it would also
probably be of assistance too so just
know the recommendation number four
there is about a bluff event at a later
date
um
to make sure that that wasn't lost in
the options
uh being discussed for here in the city
um
yeah just a point on that I mean one of
the things I constantly struggle with a
little bit is that I hear feedback from
Bluff and from Bluff Community borders
though they feel a little bit left out
of the city that's one issue but then in
having separate separate events for
Bluff as opposed to invercargill out
we're reinforcing that
so the answer is that Mr mayorism it's
up it's down to us both yes and no sure
yes it is reinforcing it because it's
showing that there is a them in us but
the other part of that is no it's also
recognizing that bluff has its own
separate
um Township that has unique interests
which is why there is a community board
um and it's important to also
acknowledge that in 1953 it was a
Borough Council and would have done
something for the coronation of the late
Queen uh and it's trying to keep that
sort of synergy and feeling alive and
Bluff again those are just wasn't true I
know you had your hand up pioneer if you
haven't you should have your hand up so
give me some guidance on this one
joining the city council and I think
that the bluff community board may have
a few on it and I just don't want to
read anything
but um I think it's important that we do
something okay I'm not sure what that
looks like we might be just planning
some trees and acknowledging
you know this is a significant
then came next
and it can be this project pointed out
yeah it can be something as simple as
taking a photo paper back to the bluff
community board and inviting them to
make a determination of what they would
like to do sure yeah I think that would
be good
oh yes I must to me I was going back to
the options
um that we're looking at and I would
also support option three
um to me the coronation the canes more
important
um then going on a delegation trip to
kumagaya
thank you
everyone
I just wanted to add to the conversation
about bluffus not to forget that this
was where the queen departed from on her
first tour of New Zealand
um there's a lot of really excellent
footage of that and I think for
honoring that link
alone is actually important that because
that's another 70-year sort of event
since
um
yeah so at least the offer should be
made to the bluff community board to see
how they would like to do that because
certainly his majesty is recommended
people plant things so I'm sure that's
Bluff
likes planting trees oh you've got that
Michael I have got that there will be
anything paper going to the given your
board thank you so for the purposes of
just putting for these motions I'll I'll
do the um recommendations
um one two and
and four together because there seems to
be no
dispute around any of those so if
someone would like to move those
Alex thank you and trash all those in
favor
carried on the issue of three
um I'll preempt that by putting in two
because I think that's what the majority
are saying and if that's defeated then
we'll look at another option so if you
can just make that
option two a mover and signature
thank you
great thank you all those in favor
opposed
oh look I'll do a show hands to make
sure that I'm not missing anybody all
those in favor just show your hands
for option two yeah that's Carrie thank
you
all right I think that's us done
in an open session would somebody like
to move that we go into public excluded
thank you Darren thank you Leslie
defaulting position just not she said
what did I vote for
all those folks say all right okay